[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
frança 24 hoy el lunes ya 18 de julio
rosa bienvenida a esta mesa de trabajo
una nueva semana informativa vamos
entonces a abrir esta revista de prensa
con un repaso por todas las portadas
europeas que coinciden en él por
supuesto destacar lo que está afectando
este continente de las temperaturas
extremas los incendios descontrolados
consecuencia anunciada de cambio
climático no rosa exactamente y de hecho
los fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
tienen lugar en muchísimos puntos del
hemisferio norte en estos momentos que
está en una la estación veraniega desde
china a medio oriente también hay
incendios en marruecos pero nos hemos
querido centrar en europa porque
precisamente ante la guerra en ucrania
la comisión europea se está planteando
volver al uso digamos a mayoritario de
combustibles fósiles como el carbón
vamos a entrar en eso a continuación
pero empecemos a por esta ronda como
bien decías de portadas europeas
empezamos a por the gardian que dice
alerta roja una ola de calor feroz
dispara las temperaturas por encima de
los 40 grados eso césped que suceda en
an reino unido
por otro lado the gardian señala que los
científicos hacen sonar la alarma y
señalan el calentamiento provocado por
la acción humana no ya digamos en nadie
pone en cuestión a nadie que digamos
crea en la ciencia pone en cuestión que
este cambio climático que ya ya está
aquí ya está afectando de forma mortal a
ya todo el planeta es una consecuencia
directa de la acción humana por otro
lado dice the gardian digamos teniendo
en cuenta cómo afecta como decíamos este
cambio climático a la salud dedica un
artículo a precisamente los efectos
sobre nuestro organismo de estas
temperaturas extremas no dice eso
corporal las temperaturas afectan a cada
parte de nuestro cuerpo la piel los
pulmones o el cerebro o el cerebro dice
en casos extremos puede provocar cáncer
embolias o incluso ataques al corazón es
que precisamente como vemos ahora en del
'times' en la situación es tal en el
reino unido- y se espera que continúe
empeorando a lo largo de esta semana no
que se superen incluso los 41 grados
y la máxima temperatura jamás registrada
en el reino unido que se registró en
2019 y fue de 38 7 grados que la policía
de londres ha emitido por primera vez la
alerta roja por calor extremo y que por
otro lado pues ya está el país en una
declaración de emergencia nacional
también el frankfurter allgemeine este
medio alemán destaca los incendios
forestales devastadores en el sur de
europa o de morgen de bélgica también
señala europa bajo temperaturas récord
con esta foto que veremos a continuación
ante los incendios en la dieron en el
suroeste de francia así es vamos a pasar
precisamente a francia rosa que amanece
con toda su costa atlántica con
temperaturas récord como lo estamos
hablando se ya los 40 grados al tiempo
que continúan ardiendo los incendios en
el suroeste del país efectivamente el
mont dedica precisamente su portada a
estos a fenómenos extremos dice canícula
que es como llaman en nada francés
canícula ola de calor incendios estado
de urgencia climática dice lemon europa
se enfrenta a una nueva semana de
récords de temperatura con los incendios
forestales como telón como telón de
fondo y señala este medio francés que
precisamente la población de francia ya
tomó conciencia de que la excepción
climática se ha convertido ya en la
norma y de que precisamente 4 de cada 5
franceses se declaran a convencidos de
la necesidad de actuar de forma
inmediata pero precisamente el editorial
de limón deplora la inacción política
climática particularmente la de francia
y vemos también algo que tiene que hacer
sonar todas las alarmas y es que parís
la capital francesa se prepara según
lemond para vivir olas de calor por
encima de los 50 grados centígrados y
también para acabar con esta ronda en
francia liberación pone una imagen de la
gironda de estos bosques que veíamos
también en el medio belga de morgen y
vemos aquí después de seis días el
bosque de la región continúa ardiendo
has pasado usted es rosa ha tenido la
oportunidad de vivir una temperatura
extrema como esta
un lugar del mundo pues digamos yo hasta
hace poco no me en mi país o también en
francia digamos las temperaturas
extremas no es algo que suceda desde
este año como decíamos ha sido una
consecuencia anunciada del cambio
climático que sí hay que ha ido
aumentando pero empeorando a lo largo de
los últimos años sin duda cuando yo
vivía ahí pues las temperaturas eran
también extremas bueno pasamos ahora a
la portada del país porque sintetiza muy
bien las prioridades políticas a corto
plazo que estamos doblando bien vemos
como en esta portada para digamos hacer
referencia esta contradicción en la que
se encuentra europa ya la que no sabemos
no sabemos si vamos a sobrevivir por un
lado tenemos esta imagen de un incendio
particularmente en el barrios en la
provincia de barcelona y con el titular
un brigadista primera víctima mortal de
la ola de incendios como decía ser en
los informativos ya son dos las víctimas
de los incendios en españa pero por otro
lado tenemos bueno para terminar con
esta información sobre los incendios
forestales nos dice el país que son 36
los incendios activos 'españa de los
cuales 24 están en nuestros momentos
descontrolados pero queríamos fijarnos
precisamente en la información que vemos
a la izquierda de esta portada que
titula la comisión europea está
dispuesta a aceptar de forma temporal
las subvenciones al carbón ante la
crisis del gas ruso y es que la comisión
europea propone relajar el control de
emisiones contaminantes como decíamos al
principio de esta crónica volviendo al
uso del carbón para producir energía
industrial y electricidad y en lo
particular no de esta situación raúl es
que durante mucho tiempo hemos hablado
de la dicotomía entre el corto y el
medio plazo no entre tener gas y
electricidad para el invierno o actuar
de acuerdo con la situación climática
que enfrenta nuestro planeta pero como
estábamos viendo hasta en esta crónica
digamos que la acción climática ya no es
una cuestión de medio plazo sino que ya
tenemos aquí el cambio climático y ya
nos estamos digamos debatiendo entre el
corto plazo y corto plazo
todo caso es destacable esto no como la
guerra en ucrania no se está haciendo
actuar con una mirada muy cortoplacista
no volviendo a los combustibles fósiles
digamos a lo que no sabemos si podremos
sobrevivir o no claro porque además como
vigorosa esta guerra hubiera sido
perfectamente un determinante para que
realmente el mundo ya se vuelque y vamos
a estar energías limpias de energías
renovables y ajá no estamos haciendo eso
sino que estamos buscando pues
obviamente más petróleo por emiratos
árabes unidos- este acercamiento de eeuu
o también con venezuela en arabia
saudita también pues por supuesto están
buscando más petróleo en vez de pues de
caer en lo que necesitamos no hay
energías limpias y renovables rosa
efectivamente y simplemente para
terminar precisamente en el país que
titula hoy esta vuelta de la comisión
europea a poner la mirada en el hay
carbón encontrábamos un especial sobre
los fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
inmortales solamente del último año al
que ya parece que nos hayamos
acostumbrado
como forma de vida
normalizada por un lado para resumir
algunos de estos fenómenos mortales que
han sucedido a lo largo del último año
tenemos una julio de 2021 recordemos
esas inundaciones en alemania y bélgica
en octubre de ese mismo año incendios
gigantescos en california y también en
canadá en la columbia británica luego
entre enero y febrero de este 2002 y
ciclones tropicales en mozambique
madagascar malawi en marzo tuvimos ola
de ola del calor polar en la antártida
luego en indian pakistán en brasil
lluvias torrenciales y esta ola de calor
rap precoz que está teniendo lugar en
europa rosa como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información mañana
con más revista de prensa pasamos a
saludar a nuestra primera invitada